I've been talking since Donald Trump was
inaugurated that as much as we have to
cover the scandal of the presidency and
the embarrassment of the presidency and
the farcical nature of the presidency we
also have to keep our eye on the things
that are done under the cover of that
scandal and embarrassment and farce and
we've talked about the extremist
reactionary judges that have been
installed likely to impact the judiciary
for a very long time after Donald Trump
is gone
and I've talked to you about the ruined
relationships with so many countries
around the world which will take a while
to repair long after Donald Trump is
gone we've talked about the
environmental deregulation that's been
done by Donald Trump and Republicans
allowing more pollution and more
destruction of the planet and dirtier
water and more and more lacks food
safety standards and I have that type of
news for you today which is that the
United States conducted a record-setting
number of bomb drops over Afghanistan in
2019 but what how didn't we hear about
this what happened how is this possible
it is the air force's Central Command
published the numbers seventy four
hundred and twenty three bombs seven
four to three bombs were dropped on
Afghanistan last year that's the highest
number in more than a decade
supposedly we weren't really in that war
anymore remember you have to go back to
2011 for a higher number of bombs
dropped on Afghanistan and at that time
we did think that we were at least sort
of at war there so on the one hand
publicly Donald Trump has said he's open
to reducing troops in Afghanistan ending
wars all of that stuff meanwhile we've
dropped a record number of bombs on
Afghanistan so did you know about this
did you know that your tax dollars while
Trump slams other presidents for the
military decisions that they made or
slammed Hillary for the military
decisions she would have made your tax
dollars have gone to a record number of
bomb drops under the trump
administration in Afghanistan we're not
winning hearts and minds there we're not
even talking about winning hearts and
minds never mind actually winning hearts
and minds
taxpayers are still paying for the bombs
the money is flowing freely to the
defense contractors and we have no idea
where why we are still there we are in
year I don't know is it 18 or 19 at this
point we must be getting really close to
dropping enough bombs for them to work
the way we want right or otherwise why
do we continue to do it it's a really
good thing that that war monger Hillary
Clinton didn't get into office and quite
frankly I don't even I'm sort of saying
that as a satire because this might be
identical under Hillary it just
continues on one under one president
under another on and on and on so this
is a story as much as it is about Donald
Trump's failed promises when it comes to
the Middle East foreign intervention
bombings war military conflict this is
also a story about the
military-industrial complex about as
much as it is about our foreign policy
and that needs to be mentioned what have
these bombs achieved for us if we had
dropped four thousand bombs last year in
Afghanistan instead of nearly eight
thousand would things be different would
we be less safe we know that there are
defense contractors that would have less
money but we would because of not
spending that money and spreading that
military
sort of approach or the use of the
military that Donald Trump claimed he
would actually reel back in it still is
being a
that it made sense to abandon the Kurds
in northern Syria right because hate
Trump promised he would get us out of
places and he would scale back and all
this stuff we are told that abandoning
the Kurds made sense for those reasons
but yet we are dropping a record number
of bombs in Afghanistan and it just goes
on and on with no end and no point and
no conclusion in sight so step one is
knowing about this and I know a lot of
people in our audience didn't know about
this I think we mentioned it briefly in
December when there were preliminary
numbers about bombs dropped in
Afghanistan we now have the final
numbers and it is absolutely sickening
what is going on I would be shocked if
any significant portion of our audience
was even aware of this
and that's part of how it continues
important to know that